[Musique]
béatrice martin alias coeur de pirate
est à la fois artiste et gestionnaire
depuis que la fait l'acquisition il ya
six mois de l'étiquette dare to care
records dont en fait ça va super bien je
me dis fois je me surprends moi même des
jeux comme ok d'accord j'ai plus de 100
fois que je pensais avec son étiquette
désormais baptisé bravo musique
coeur de pirate fait partie du nombre
grandissant de femmes qui veulent gérer
l'industrie musicale d'ici un artiste à
la fois
moi j'apporte la confiance nécessaire
pour que ces partis se développe un peu
comme qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec moi
finalement
la pianiste alexandra stréliski est
aussi entrepreneur elle est devenue
actionnaire du studio la majeure je les
fais dans un souci de premièrement pour
assumer mon côté entrepreneurial parce
que je pense que souvent les femmes
n'assume pas forcément leur côté
entrepreneurial et qu'on l'a cette fibre
là ça prend le courage et ça prend la
mise en action
non
cette volonté de s'investir et d'être à
la tête de sa propre entreprise est de
plus en plus présente
catherine simard a fondé la maison
fauves et parmi ces artistes on retrouve
entre autres
patrice michaud vincent vallières et
élire aux j'étais rendu un point dans ma
vie où j'avais plus envie de demander de
permission à personne j'avais envie de
faire mes propres choses moi je sens
dans la dernière année surtout qu'ils
rêvaient de changement les femmes sont
de plus en plus visible
ce vent de changement chez les
gestionnaires bénéficie aux artistes
féminines comme celles de chez bravo
musique c'est beau de donner la chance
aussi
pippo juste de donner la chance de
donner à plat ce que ces femmes la
mairie est en fait le talent je pense
qu'il est toujours été là jusque là on a
une tribune peut-être plus grande pour
eux pour le montrer malgré ce bel élan
il y aurait encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
si on regarde le conseil
d'administration de l'adisq c'est
majoritairement des hommes
en ce moment on est rendu à un point où
ça prouve que c'est peut-être d'être pas
de discrimination positive pour rétablir
l'équilibré chose
moi j'ai envie juste d'encourager celles
qui l'ont cette fibre là à la mettre en
action
[Musique]
des voix féminines s'élèvent dans la
musique d'ici et leurs échos résonnent
au diapason ici oui philippe ouimet
radio canada n'ont rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]